Film Courage: How do you know if an idea is
worth developing into a story?
Patricia Vidal Delgado, Writer/Director: I
have a sounding board who is…I guess he's
kind of my secret weapon…but he's someone
who has seen all of my short films and he's
always the first person I go to with an idea
even at a treatment stage to be like Is this
any good or is this really terrible?
If it's really terrible can I salvage it?
Is there a way to make it better?
It's a very good friend called Faisal A. Qureshi.
He's a professional screenwriter based in
the UK.
He's also directed films.
I think it's very important as a writer to
be able to show someone that you trust something
that you're not entirely sure if it's any
good or not because he knows me well enough
now that he knows he can be really harsh and
it’s okay because at the end of the day
I just want to know if I am wasting my time
or not.
And he has been very harsh and I really appreciate
it because I have had instances where I have
sent a treatment and he’ll tell me what
is wrong with it like in a very kind of brutal
way.
But then that’s good because it helps me
figure out how I can make it better and I
have actually been able to make it better
and get onto fellowships with treatments that
before he was like [makes face and shakes
head no] “Hmmm?
I don’t think so?”
Film Courage: Does he reciprocate where he
sends you his scripts?
Patricia: He does, yes.
He has sent me his materials before.
So definitely.
I think that it’s so important is to have
someone because I think I always feel like
in this industry you only get one chance to
impress people so you want to put your best
foot forward.
That’s why it’s important to have someone
whose opinion you trust and whose craft you
really admire and you recognize that they
are really talented and intelligent and you
can show them your worst stuff and they will
give you suggestions and will tell you what
you could do to make it a little bit better.
Film Courage: Does he ever ask you to be more
harsh?
Patricia: Oh yeah!
Film Courage: Because I can see you not wanting
to hurt someone’s feelings?
Patricia: Absolutely.
And he’s like “Just be honest.
Please, just tell me.”
Because I do, I always think “I don’t
want to hurt anybody’s feelings.”
Film Courage: I think that would be really
important to have a working relationship or
a friendship where you can give them feedback
(and vice versa) and you know they are not
trying to wound you to stop you.
They are just trying to help make you better.
That’s a rare thing to find.
Patricia: Absolutely so that’s why a big
shout out to Faisal.
And I think someone because they’ve kind
of read your previous work and have seen your
previous films that they know what you’re
trying to do and because of that they can
tell you “I think I know what you’re trying
to do but you’re maybe not doing it the
best way that you could it?
So let me just ask you some questions and
make some suggestions because I think I know
what you’re trying to get?”
I think that is very important because there
are some people who just don’t understand
your work and don’t understand your films
and don’t want to are maybe not the best
people to get feedback from.
Film Courage: How do you know personally if
your movie idea isn’t working?
Not so much if you’ve given it to someone
as a sounding board but personally?
Patricia: I think it’s when you yourself
are writing it and you’re not excited by
what you’re writing.
I think you know that it’s working when
you’re like I really want to keep going.
I personally want to know what happens next.
But if you’re kind of like trudging through
it and Oh gosh I have to write another five
pages or I have to write another five paragraphs
of this treatment.
If you yourself are having that thought, trust
me whoever is reading it is going to also
have the same thought of Oh gosh I have to
write another five pages before this is over.
Film Courage: Have you ever abandoned an idea?
Like you’ve been excited about it for a
little while and then realize that your heart
wasn’t in it?
Patricia: I think yes definitely but I think
more with like I have had that with a feature
script which I was like this is not working
as a feature but I managed to kind of recycle
it into something else and then also short
films like if you’ve written a short film
script that was a collaboration with a friend
and then you applied to a lot of funding and
you just keep getting rejected and then it’s
like well okay then let’s just not.
Film Courage: So the universe was telling
you something or you just took it that way?
Patricia: And then you just move onto the
next project because that got funding Okay
well then I’ll just do that.
Question: How do you know an idea is worth
developing into a story?